scale of the devastation is hard to
Fathom as rescue workers desperately
search for survivors in the biting cold
some people still trapped under the
rubble are posting videos of themselves
on social media begging for help the
early morning 7.8 magnitude earthquake
struck as most people slept since then
there have been dozens of aftershocks
the most recent and strongest measuring
7.5 so little has been spared including
the city of gaziantep's historic Castle
which has stood for over 2 000 years
parts of it now in Ruins just over the
border and the last Rebel controlled
corner of Syria which is packed with
some 4 million people displaced from the
country's long and brutal Civil War even
more misery as the smallest survivors
are pulled from the rubble